i'm gonna make another example to you
why you always bet on the entrepreneur
always bet on the entrepreneur always so
check this out
in 2009 an obama-led committee said
listen instead of putting all this money
into going into space who cares about
this anyways
it would take 12 years and 26 billion
dollars
to go to space and return why would we
want to put 26 billion dollars into it
again government obama led 2009. so man
shows up
okay his name is elon musk he doesn't
have the government he doesn't have any
of that stuff he's just a regular
entrepreneur maybe a crazy entrepreneur
he's definitely somebody that's going to
push the envelope and disrupt
going up against the government so 12
years 26 billion dollars
he ends up doing it in six years one
billion dollars
less than a billion dollars they fly
into space for two weeks
and they return safely with the two
astronauts that went out there
everything's fine they're back you can
reuse the spacecraft they used to get up
there
how did this happen it's called an
entrepreneur
who has experience knowing i dare you to
tell me i cannot do it
i dare you challenge tell me we cannot
do it
we'll go pull it off and he pulls it up
so now what could be the next thing i
don't know if you've heard what he said
he says we're going to go to mars we're
going to go to space
and people are going to be living both
in space and here
this is what he's projecting now a lot
of people are listening to him saying
this kind of stuff so
you you watch one too many star wars you
watch one too many star trek you watch
one too many fiction movies and one too
many of these novels that's about
what's in space but elon musk is very
serious about it no no no no
we're gonna go there and live out there
you're gonna have a home here
and rich people are gonna have a home
over there and they're gonna be able to
go to different places
can you imagine the way this guy thinks
and logical thinkers who think inside
the box what do they say
12 years and 26 billion dollars
according to our calculation
less than a billion and six years what's
the moral of the story here here's a
moral of the story
when you have a committee that you have
to get a decision approved by another
person and another person and another
person and another person
let me think about it and another person
and another person and another person
and then
70 people i got to get through in the
government to get something approved
this is why entrepreneurship work let's
go and see if we can test this out for
less
than a billion dollars let's do it one
person
is the difference step process one
this is why you can't compete with a
startup led by a proper
innovator disrupting that's exactly what
elon musk is he keeps doing the
impossible so again
the next time somebody tries to convince
you that the government can do good with
money and
invest back into anything better always
come back and see entrepreneurs can do
it faster and cheaper
nasa has been around for a long time
a lot of experience an independent
governmental agency
nasa right now a company called spacex
8 000 employees founded in 2002 one of
the founders elon musk we can do it in a
year and six in
in six years and spend less than a
billion dollars and the reason why i'm
sharing this with you
is because there's nothing more powerful
than an entrepreneur
who knows how to think big and execute
so if you're watching this this week
and you see somebody that tells you
bobby there's no way in the world it's
going to take you this much time
and this much money to do it you just
say watch me do it okay
that's the challenge the entrepreneur
wants the entrepreneurs
dying for somebody to tell them you
cannot do it
and if you want to think big as well as
an entrepreneur here's a video i did i
don't know three four years ago if
you've never watched it's a very
specific detailed
video on how to think like an
entrepreneur having said that
i challenge you to think big this week
[Music]